I don't always mean to give you a
but it just it's just but it
happens but this is the truth dude
there's no one really better than you
dude I'm gonna get a from some
of those sounds the guy very soft hands
for a man for like a guy who's in a you
know like a straight man soft his hands
in a straight male Community sound
volcano even the stuff that people talk
about me on it's so whatever it's
some young Comics who are all into their
sneaker or whatever so if that
shirt beef with me fine and then there
was a time where some snitch in
L.A where can people see you next except
for the snitch yeah except for
that snitch snitch
you know who you are yeah no we
don't but you know that's enough to do
was come to me like a man after the show
and go hey there's another comedian with
a similar thought but you didn't do that
did you because you like drama
[Music]